now there is one bit of sanity in the
context of this completely obvious and
partisan attempt from House Republicans
to distract from the robert muller
investigation by saying the house
investigation into trump russia
collusion is over for the most part we
are seeing republicans say there's just
nothing here we did a full and totally
credible investigation and that's
absolutely it there is however one
Republican on the House Intelligence
Committee who has a little bit of a
different view which is that it's the
investigation that has lost credibility
and that's the reason why it needs to
end and it happens to be Florida
Republican Congressman Tom Rooney Tom
Rooney was interviewed yesterday by Erin
Burnett he admits the investigation was
completely off the rails he says there
is evidence that Russians work to help
Trump although the extent to which that
took place he is unsure about and he
also said that this is an investigation
that lost credibility let's listen to
the congressman if you're saying yes you
have seen evidence of this but it sounds
like there's disagreement frankly
between Republicans on your committee
well exactly where it is if the Senate
again emphasizing the Senate has
intended there's Bob Muller has intended
there's what why are you all ending it
well two things for what I said last
week that we've gone completely off the
rails and now we're just basically a
political forum for people to leak
information to drive the day's news so
we've as use as you alluded to we've
lost all credibility and we're going to
issue probably two different reports
unfortunately so I'm in that regard I
that's why I called for the
investigation and but if there's
anything that we can come together to do
to help protect us in 2018 we just had a
primary last week in Texas we've got an
election tomorrow in Pennsylvania if we
don't get any of these recommendations
out before this cycle gets fully
underway then then we really have just
completely wasted a year of everybody's
time yes so that there's a lot there
right number one you had Republicans and
Democrats participating on the house
intelligence committees investigation of
Trump Russia they sat in the same room
they heard the same evidence they
participated and listening to the exact
same witness
and you will have two diametrically
opposed reports as to the facts of what
took place there that shows that this is
not about going beyond party and
thinking about the impact that other
countries can have on the actual or
perceived stability of American
democracy it's just totally partisan
number two he mentions today's
Pennsylvania election in the context of
this Republican report and that's
interesting to me because one angle has
been the reason Republicans did this
yesterday is they're very worried about
a release from robert muller coming up
soon the other angle which is less
convincing to me but interesting
nonetheless is that Republicans know
that tonight in a special Pennsylvania
election in a district that Trump won
over Hillary Clinton by about 20 points
in the 2016 election a Democrat might
win and that it is yet another attempt
to preemptively distract from that I
don't know which it is but what I do
find interesting is that Tom Rooney is
not running for re-election and much
like other retiring Republicans remember
Republican Senator Jeff Flake from
Arizona they seem to have grown a spine
when they're all of a sudden not running
for anything anymore and this actually
really makes me think we're onto
something when we think about term
limits when they don't have to go back
and face the donors or when they no
longer care about Trump hate tweeting
them into oblivion and oblivion and
maybe affecting their re-election
chances they start making an ounce of
sense but I I would make the case that
retiring alone isn't enough they are
still complicit in what's taken place up
to this point and I would have preferred
to hear from Tom Rooney earlier in the
investigation that his party is not
taking it seriously that they are doing
everything they can to just end it
sooner than later because it's great
that he's saying this now but it would
have been more useful to know it before
so that maybe something could have been
done about it and and coming soon by the
way the Democratic version of the end of
the investigation report which will no
doubt be drastically different than the
Republican one so different that both
couldn't possibly be true we will
we will learn about the totally distinct
realities that the Republican memo
alludes to versus the Democratic memo on
this and that's the real tragedy right
which should be a question about the
basic integrity of our voting systems
and our democracy and the sovereignty of
American electoral decision-making has
become partisan how much do we want to
stop others from meddling in our
elections it seems the answer depends on
the party affiliation and whether your
guy benefited from the alleged meddling
it's disappointing and it's quite
frankly really depressing send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter a david
pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by brilliant if you watch our
channel or listen to the podcast yeah
you're into politics and you follow the
daily news and you want to be informed
about the world around you but maybe you
also want to dig a little deeper and on
the program we talk about climate change
in taxes and technology political
philosophy to really understand these
issues at a deeper fundamental level you
have to familiarize yourself with with
what's actually sort of underpinning all
of it and that's math and philosophy and
the hard sciences and social sciences
and that's where brilliant comes in it's
a truly unique and innovative online
learning service which lets you master
important real-world math and science
concepts this includes probability and
statistics logic and problem solving
renewable energy climate science
criminology you name it and you can get
started right the second by signing up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman the first 200 people who do that
at brilliant org slash David Pakman will
also qualify for 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
slash David Pakman check it out today